okay
all right
all right
welcome to the uh
september
community strategy committee meeting
um we're obviously doing a bit of
zooming and there's various people
scattered around various parts of the
building and also um
various parts of the community and thank
you for the ones that are dialed in and
i'm going to do some presentation there
so if there's any issue just singing out
we can stop um if we lose sound or
um visual audio because i know during
this there is a few
uh and then or back me up there there's
a few presentations or we're gonna do
some shared screen stuff uh or visuals
as well
so um just if there's an issue just make
sure
stop me
uh
i don't think we've got any apologies
on the floor
and uh we have the agenda agenda before
us i don't think there's any stats uh
stat statutes uh state statements or
declaration or anything like that
on any of the topics we've got today
um just
just one thing
mr chair
with regard to
tussock country
myself and um
councillor reed trustees there
um and we're there
in our own right i guess but we're also
there on behalf of the council so i just
need to clear that
okay as long as we got there recorded in
the minutes and i'm sure that will be
fine
um so if we start just working through
our agenda and welcome to um jeff i know
he's coming he's indicated he's not
milking so a lovely day to be out in the
country today but um
we have a uh item one on our agenda is
um a report on the tusk country music
festival um and there's obviously a
fairly detailed report there
that
we've received and i don't know whether
uh do you want to start ann or jeff um
to lead into this
and thanks mr chair so um jeff and i've
had a conversation about today and just
sent through a video which i'm going to
share
with you which gives you a little bit of
insight to the last festival but you'll
be aware that there was a lot of work
green turned to getting all things
country music coordinated under the
banner of tussock country and then um
first round of covert meant that they
couldn't actually
run the festival so this year was the
first
opportunity for them and i think it was
very successful
and the team have done a great job so um
jeff i'll just share the video and and
then you can take over
sure that'll be great
so hopefully you can see it on your
screen is that correct now
yep okay
[Music]
friday
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so for those of you who have maybe
attended some of it might brought back a
few memories
i think i think from the tussock country
board perspective
uh we were pretty delighted with how we
managed to pull it off for the first
year
you only get one crack at doing it the
first time and we were pretty conscious
that
it was important that
it did go as well as we
we would hope and i think it did
i think i think we managed um
a few recollections the weather was
actually great that week um for people
popping down was was didn't do us any
harm at all
we think there was pretty good buy-in uh
on the whole from
from the region from our locals
there were some sold out shows that had
never really happened before
and
we had some
we had some tour buses from the north
island down visiting and so uh
i think they went away pretty pretty
chaffed if they'd come
from the board perspective i think you
know there's a huge state of gratitude
to the sponsors we were fortunate in
receiving a couple of grants
to help get this thing off the ground
but um
if if i was to look back at the at the
journey this has been
um
uh
good district councils have been
you know
probably the backbone of making this
happen
both with manpower and financial backing
and really two people were instrumental
in making this a reality
while we have a great board
firstly anne who's obviously here you
know with the council funding she
she set us really on a track that
we wouldn't have been able to get on
without her expertise
and
she invested over and above
to try and get a foundation and then
covert came along and messed it all up
but
but the foundations were in place and
they were set and um
and so anne's ann's input to
the success of the festival while not
there at
festival time 21
was very significant
and i guess as a board and we would like
to say thank you
to you and have that minister because it
was it was immense
without that foundation we wouldn't have
been able to pull it off number two
also funded by the district council is
annabel roy i don't know how many of you
have met annabelle most of you probably
um and i think we got the right person
for the job
had some good applicants for the role
but annabelle um
lots of skills lots of experience
and not afraid to roll the sleeves up
and get on with it that needs to be done
uh whether i'd send you a job
description or not so
so really those two people
have been foundational in pulling this
off without question
[Music]
around our board table now we have
a member from auckland
uh
whose
financial and governance experience is
significant
we have jenny mitchell
who brings a perspective that
a is youthful
and b is a very successful artist so she
brings a great uh a great perspective
that's hugely helpful to us as a board
matt wilson is also another new trustee
and matt's experience
as a musician also but also as as a
marketing guy
and as a as a planning strategic guy um
really three
significant um
additions to the board and of course
tracy in
bronwyn
uh
julian mitchell phillip geary
kerry macleod
you've got to be careful you don't miss
somebody up when you get around the
table
um
i think that's it
and um yeah a really good board with
with a broad skill set
um
at two tuscan country events that were
new were obviously top paddock
and the youth muster gwd youth luster
and
while top paddock had a history of
success in a big following
we
initially were not really sure how that
would translate into an indoor
winter
event
but it
it worked very well and um
it it showed me that actually the
following of top paddock is is
significant and people came from all
over the country to come
to see that to be
in gore and so that was pretty
successful
we we sold it out at 850 uh patrons
because
once again we wanted to get as good as
we could the first time and not just
add another 150 tickets on just to sell
the tickets
we wanted it to be a good uh i mean
you'll have you will have read some of
the feedback that annabelle has
circulated
always things we can do better and
and uh already have have looked at some
of those
in putting in place
the ute master was a complete
throw caution to the wind and see what
happens
and
i think strangely enough you know we got
a couple of minutes on the project
about the youth master on tv three and
in it it
it ticked a wee box for us in terms of
being a little different
pickup trucks and country music have
always gone hand in hand
and so we always hoped it would be a
good fit and i think i think it has been
uh once again the the
going forward with the utmaster gwd have
already signed up
and are very keen to be a partner in
that and have also
assigned some man parents and roles for
next year
so
we we look forward to to both the top
pedic and the master becoming
better run
more significant
bigger potentially
and
not initially but i think down the line
venues may have to change but we want to
we want to
walk before we run
and we want to walk really well before
we run actually
so
[Music]
in terms of in terms of going forward um
you know we've got some goals and
recommendations that was on one of on
page nine of your report
our agm was to be tomorrow night
but
we decided to to postpone
really for the reasons that we'd rather
sit around face to face with people
without stupid masks on whether we can
do that or not we'll see but we're going
to give it a couple of weeks and if we
can pull that off
and have a uh some sort of level one agm
where people can visit with each other
uh that's that was a plan that will be
our plan uh obviously we've got
financials that will be reported there
um that we'd like to share with everyone
so when that annual meeting is tied down
we'll let certainly ann know
and
we can uh we can share that information
with you
uh
probably all be it to say that uh
from uh from a financial perspective
the first year went very well
that's probably enough from me
um
[Music]
mr chair thanks to you
thanks for jeff thanks for the video for
those that um i dare say there's
probably quite a few of the councillors
sitting around there that uh
went to a number of the venues and
probably enjoyed a lot of it firsthand
um
really uh and is there anything you'd
like to add before i open it up for
comment from the
counselors or queries
no i think um the only thing i would say
is that
you know there was
a significant increase in economic
return to our community and it's only
going to grow
and i would say that
all the feedback that i've heard
from the community it was really really
positive and i think you know the
foundation set um from jeff and his team
to go forward and be stronger for next
year so well done to the end
okay
okay thanks ed um
from the floor we've obviously got the
report here and we've heard from jeff
any queries problems or questions that
we want to um discuss in relation to
that
i
no i meant mr chia i don't want to ask
any questions but i just want to endorse
what um jeff has said
about the success of the endeavour and
and i think every one of us that sat
around that board table were a little
bit nervous as we got closer and closer
to the event coming on
[Music]
in terms available what this is going to
be but we needed to try and to have 70
plus utes turn up and everybody have a
fantastic time and want to come wanting
to come back next year was
was just a real bonus so
to to everybody and there's a huge
number of volunteers that uh are
involved in this process
uh sure there's some professional um
artists and musicians that are involved
as well but if it wasn't for the
volunteers on the ground
it wouldn't wouldn't have occurred and
uh i just um give a big ups to them
so from from my perspective and as i say
i'm probably a little bit biased
i think this is a really good fit for
for our community and in this council
and will only get stronger as as time
goes on
thanks tracy um any further commentary
there
okay
so we have the report as read obviously
just from the chairs role here
good report it's got some great stats in
there jeff i'm sure that the committee
are going to go and have a look at that
and from the community point of view
you know it's just under 1.7 million
dollars into the economy
um that can't be uh
can't be overlooked um
particularly from that start with the
covert environment and we're living in
an unusual
uh landscape at the moment so i dare say
the thinking hats will be on around what
what we're heading into and how next
year's going
and obviously we have that backing for
the next few years which um we no doubt
will be looking at and we appreciate
those uh favorable comments about the
council and the council role and support
we've had there in that position um it's
good because i know that um it was
discussed about
you know what what outcomes were going
to come from this and i believe it's
only going to get better so no thank you
very m thanks from the council to you
jeff because i know you've been
a fairly key pivotal person one of the
mainstays there um in this project so
uh if someone would like to recommend
that reports received
venice and
bronwen yep
everything that jeff and his worship and
anne have said um
it was a big learning curve for a lot of
us i think when tuan came on the scene
we just had you know maybe one new event
but no it was all
um very professionally done and we were
very grateful for the help that she gave
us in setting it up but also like to
make a comment about
carla brotherston
now carla was assigned to keep the notes
for us at the meetings and i mean
at that weekend she was helping at every
event that we had so that's just
indicative of the um the effort that
some people went to because they could
see that it was going to be a really
successful weekend so
on modern upward thank
[Music]
you okay uh thank you council reid uh so
i've had that recommended and received
um appreciate your time jeff
my pleasure
uh thank you thank thanks for it you
know
we will look forward to seeing you all
face face-to-face at some stage
okay thanks jeff cheers bye-bye
moving through the uh number two on the
agenda there and we
moving to is it jess and
um
gemma
from active southland
are we looking
yes we do have
i've got multiple screens and i can't
see everyone you sort of flick through
so
um we have the uh obviously the actual
south and
uh report before us there and um i don't
know whether you want to lead into that
and we'll just leave it to just some
german
i'll just make the comment that this is
um the year end report to the 30th of
june uh 2021 and i have met uh with both
gsm meeting with gemma on friday
and it's very evident to me there's a
lot of work and good work going on in
the ghoul district and um active south
and i'm really keen to continue the
partnership um
earth school district council so i'm
going to hand over to gemma and jess and
they might like to give us a little bit
of an update especially around
the name change and i think the thing
that really came through to me in my
discussions with jess was the huge
amount of work going on within the
well-being space
so i'll hand over to eugene ranges
um thank you so much for this
opportunity i really appreciate the
chance to to speak with you and and to
kind of bring this report a wee bit to
life
um i'm jess domingue and i'm the general
manager here at active south and gemma
is our um eastern connector home i'm
sure that you all know her face and
worked with her already
um we just did want to touch on that
name change obviously when we spoke to
the long-term um submission we were
still sport south and now we've changed
active south and so we just thought that
was a good opportunity to
um
just let you in on kind of where that's
come from we did a lot of consultation
with our community
and really have changed to active south
and to better represent the type of work
we are doing and i think that speaks to
the report that you have in front of you
um we really
haven't forgotten about sport but
the breadth of work and the scope that
we're able to do is really across
well-being as a whole our vehicle being
physical activity
um
so yeah we better this name better
reflects where we're at and i think the
conversations with and have
been really useful in terms of opening
up those conversations and opportunities
for us to support further into the gore
district so we're really excited to do
that
um
jimmy did you want to add to anything to
that
no that's exactly right we
especially a bit about not forgetting
about sport that's still part of what we
do and you can see that in the report
but the fact that we've um that name
change reflects that wide scope you can
see in the report that we cover so many
bases and um supporting the community
where we can in any way and we've always
got an open door to anybody that wants
to come and talk about anything else so
um yeah yeah that's still my part of it
thank you
we're happy to take any questions on the
report or any thing you might have for
us
um thanks guys uh and have you got
anything you want to add to
add to the commentary there just
regarding obviously where we
some of the councils probably might be a
wee bit of a 101
around um what you guys you know the
involvement and where you're based and
uh and that sort of thing
um and you know a lot of us
the actions aren't actually active
sports
like sports base is such a variation and
broad spectrum of what you actually do
i don't know whether
councils be interested in all that or
they
are happy with what they're seeing in
the report there
any commentary there from
just you just want to cover off a little
bit more about the well-being side of
things to
so that people are aware yeah i guess
it's been an
exciting
part of growth for the eastern part of
our work
we have
the healthy active learning team a part
of the school
workforce in terms of looking at
well-being for children but it's
strengthening teachers confidence
around the health and
pe
curriculum in school so we work
alongside teachers to build their
confidence in in working in that space
we also now have
teams of we have always had green
prescription for a long time in gwa but
we're strengthening that work with gore
health um center and or medical center
in terms of looking at people's
well-being as a whole so that's
supporting mental well-being in the
practice um as well as out into the
community so that's been a new part of
our work that we're really excited about
um
what else there's there's lots i guess
we all know that being active is good
for your well-being and i guess through
lockdown and covert we've seen a lot
more people out and about and it's
helping people make those links
to to the value of physical activity for
your well-being so there's plenty more
we could do and i've had some
discussions around crossover with
rangatahi employment um and and the work
that they think mark's doing in that
space as well as they're ready for
living um and older people's um false
prevention that kind of work that we're
involved with already
and through you mr chair and jesus and i
their attention is that
jesus team and our team are going to get
together and um you know develop some
plans that cross over into our
workspaces
and we intend to come back to the
community strategy committee early in
the new year as part of a workshop just
to expand out and show you
the types of work that's going on in a
district
yeah it's um it's uh
the report there covers off so many
different um
different aspects and various things
that um are happening and it's actually
good that there is that interaction
there between the obviously the workings
some of those plans have been kicking
along for quite a few years with really
living and some of those um
ones that have developed over the last
three or four years and everyone linking
in
which is um good to see and the linkage
between that and the community strategy
manager and mark i think he's online
there
there's a fair bit of networking going
on
um which we sort of it's hard to measure
sometimes the actual um successes that
you get um a lot of it's
it's not a tangible measurement but um
it's it's there
um is there any other commentary from
councillors there uh brahman have you
stood your hand up from before was it
and again i don't want to ask any
questions but i just want to
say thank you to active south and for
the report that you've given
and
um and probably all the councils know
that we've had a very long connection to
what was sport south and are now active
south and and you know two of the
the enterprises that sort of come
straight to my mind is the office you
have at the multisport centre and and
just how integrated you are into to our
community um but also the the moonshine
trail which is probably one of our most
successful events in terms of drawing
people from right across
a target south and maybe even into
canterbury um and and it really shows
off this place as a as a wonderful place
to to be so so what you've done in the
past is 4000 thank you um but certainly
the well-being focus that you've got now
i think is going to bring some real
rewards for this community and as
richard says sometimes it's very hard to
to measure uh the outcomes of that
but
certainly from what i see um it's
wonderful so so thank you
thank you
many other questions there hands up i'm
not missing anyone
around the screens
okay so uh thank you jesse gemma um
we have the report received there
councillors um if we just have someone
recommend that it's received
uh cliff and secretary neville all those
in favor
thank you guys go out and enjoy the
sunshine thank you thanks everyone bye
okay um over there now we agenda through
item three is the uh over 80 years
parking permit i'm not sure is kylie or
francis
stay online kylie and francis are with
us they're under mark's tag you'll see
them richard
okay
okay right i'm with you email the screen
hi guys um we've obviously got a
report there um it's obviously come out
ready for living in our projects that
have been going uh and i do say do you
guys want to lead us through what um
what's there
um
and give us an overview
um yep so
good afternoon brown so um
we
um it was always part of the plan
and ready for living for the last two
years sitting there um to look into 80
plus parking free for residents in the
gore district
and we've just done some research around
what happens around lots of other
communities in
new zealand on how this works and the
different options they have
um and have done
a bit of work on why it's important
around helping those with mobility
issues
and the higher number of older people
and how we can help them and reduce the
risk of falls as well
um
without having
to um
go into the parking meters
as much
with the impaired vision and balance
yeah
anything to add francis
um i think it's a good idea um
as collie said it's to help maybe bring
the older people out into the community
and it's something that we we can offer
um to those still driving um to get them
out and about
um
not all of them have mobility issues and
are the holder of a mobility card so
this will allow them to use amended
space as well
for the um allowable time of two hours
which is the limit on a metered parking
space
so yeah we think it's a pretty good idea
and
hopefully the you know the older
residents in the district don't get
behind it
okay
um obviously the details of the um the
examples on uh from other areas there no
there's a number of other areas around
surrounding us have
had this in place
um
and really i'll open it up to the
councillors to um
to ask questions and uh and discuss this
this before us so i see bronwyn's hand
up there
councillor reed
thank you richard um
really good report and it's a wonderful
initiative
i must admit it's not something that's
ever occurred to me
but
you know when you look back and see in
the in the
uh comments there that
approximately 750 people three years ago
were aged 80 plus
so even assuming
half of them are still driving i mean
i can't see that there's anything wrong
with this i just think it's a great
initiative for the elderly in the area
and i look forward to using it myself in
days years to come
days there counselor read
that surely can't be right
um
uh any other discussion there
but uh just um endorse what uh bromine
said i think it's a no-brainer for me it
just makes makes sense with who we are
and the
demographics of their particular
community i think there's
the data 481 over 80 or 80 year olds
with a car license
there's quite a lot of people
and
and
and some of you will know that as time
goes on um
maneuvering cars and whatever uh can be
a little bit more difficult and there's
always a reticence to get out into into
the community if we can
offer
um an incentive for people to go then i
think it makes sense i think it also
fits with um
the age-friendly um nature of this
community and and counselors will be
aware that we're one of i think it's
only uh two or three
um
uh cities or towns in this country that
have got age friendly uh accreditation
from the world health organization um so
i think that it just makes a makes a lot
of sense for me that we should be going
down this trip
okay uh i've got uh councillor dixon
then council phillips
dennis
thank you
um i just like to say that i support the
recommendation as well because i
i often um hear elderly people saying
that they've got to rush away um to get
back to their parking meter
um and i think it's a really good
initiative i support it
thank you
uh
council phillips neville
thank you
mr chairman just i've got to cover just
a quick question
the sticker on the windscreen is it
going to be
so that it can be actually um
like stuck on the windscreen so it's not
removable only when the
the seller is selling the car
that's the plan um to have a little
small sticker that they can attach to
the outside of their window screen
we we're touring with a few um sort of
templates and ideas to sort of work out
what years they've been issued so while
virginia is out and about she's got some
sort of idea when the ticket that the
sticker was issued to the to the person
driving
also it will
help them not lose it we do find the odd
person with mobility cards they slip
down between the seats and the cars and
they can't find them and they switch
them from vehicles to vehicles and
unfortunately there are some people that
don't use them the way they should be
using them
so this is issue to the person
that they can attach to their own
vehicle and if they've got two cars well
we can deal with that on an individual
basis
there'll be some sort of barcode system
that virginia just puts a machine up
against the windscreen and
tells you well they have
a record of
the registration numbers of the cars
that the stick has been attached to
the person driving the car
will go through all of that and setting
up the um the database to keep a list of
who we've got
and ginny knows most of our residents
she's pretty pretty friendly with a lot
of them
um
so i think it in a small community i
think it should be not too hard to
manage in that respect
no i think it's a really good initiative
and well done i think the next one we
need to do is the camp event so that's
the next one
thanks
thank you i think also um
probably there'll be other initiatives
springing out of this one or morph out
of this one and you know one that's
already been raised with me uh some time
ago and we've never really gone too much
further with it is a similar sort of
approach to access to the pool
for people of this sort of age group
okay uh any other questions there for
kylie or francis
no that's nikki's cat i thought it was a
hand but it's definitely
um
no i think
as everyone else said i think as
chairman i think it's a great initiative
and
good work it was one of those things
that has dropped out of those projects
and there is other goodies there that
will come as well
and i think council phillips probably
alluding to what i thought is the old
policeman in me that these permits might
move around vehicles and perhaps the
person might look a bit younger than 80
that's driving
but no doubt with gorban gore and
their good staff they'll be able to work
that out and keep an eye on it so
we have this before us
recommendations so do i get someone to
move if there's no further
discussion i've got a mover there
bromwood
and seconded by nebel
um
obviously sorry councillor reed and
councillor phillips
all those in favor
[Music]
against
uh carried
thank you councillors and uh thank you
francis and kylie thank you thanks
thanks
[Music]
okay i think we are changing seats here
now
we have the next contestant comes in
um
and next to the item is the
[Music]
report on the update in regard to the
mural task force
for jobs and i know mark will have some
great details here some great content
there and i know we're um
ticking along
very very well um
sort of had a few updates informally so
uh the floor is yours whether you
whether anne wants to lead in or mark
i'll leave it to you to speak to the
councillors
mark i'll let you speak to your report
excellent
thank you mr chair afternoon everyone
um you'll have seen in the report that
um by the end of the last fiscal year
june 31st we
supported 55 placements in all um which
was um great news over a six-month
period and that
positively impacted on 39 local
businesses and the reason that that is a
lower number is because we actually fund
per person rather than per business
um
out of those 55 and five either
relocated or returned to gore which is
great news
um people want to be in gore
um and we've only had one of those
placements fall over
since their support was put in place and
that's only because they've relocated to
invercargill so they're going to take
with them first aid training and some
newfound skills hopefully into a new
place
placement sooner rather than later
um since then we've had a further eight
placements that have been supported
um
i i guess the number isn't as high as we
may have expected but largely down to
the lockdown
so that takes us to 63 placements
overall
one of those new placements uh was as a
result of advertising in the local media
three were worked by word of mouth from
other businesses
and four were as a result of the scoping
exercises that we carried out twice um
in the last fiscal year
and that's been such a huge success that
we are going to look at doing that again
in the near future
um
the hub which was our pop-up job shop
run by hokunuihuinui who we worked in
collaboration with
has since closed unfortunately um
but i do have to say that the number of
placements made were largely from the
scoping exercise rather than walk-ins
into the hub
so we are therefore going to pick up the
pastoral care side of things
and we have recently yesterday in fact
interviewed a couple of candidates to
take up a new
closing the gaps navigator role to
support that process
and we feel that and we've found the
right person
i'm really excited about taking her on
um
we have
maintained close contact with the high
schools
and we are looking to support a number
of students on gateway program going
into placements locally in the coming
weeks so that number of eight could
dramatically increased in the coming
couple of months
um
we still continue to experience that
imbalance between the amount of work out
there and the number of people taking up
those positions
we regularly have about a hundred
positions uh advertised on the new
closing the gaps website which went live
a couple of months ago
um
but filling those positions is still
proving to be somewhat problematic um
we are working on a proposal for
um
increasing
the opportunities for high school
students to gain their driver licenses
before they leave school or immediately
after in support of taking up those
placements
we have
at the last count we only had six people
in the two high schools in
gore with a full license uh ready to go
out into the working world so we need to
um support
a way of
increasing that number
um
and i guess the the um
great news moving forward as well is
that we've streamlined the whole process
of applying for jobs looking for jobs
through our website um and that's
working really well people are
submitting applications online and
the process is working a lot
quicker and yeah better
um
we're also um happy to be supporting
people with health and disability
challenges moving forward as well and
that's a new initiative that we've
instigated and
we're working on that currently to see
how we can support that process
any questions
around the screens open to the
counselors for discussion
just through the chair um mark i was
wondering you know back to the driving
licences um so you've got a three-month
waiting list
it's
um for the backlog it's really important
for the young ones that want to work in
the rural community particularly to be
able to get the jobs so is there any way
that um
that can be sped up i mean
so how is that working who are the
companies that you're working with to
put them through those licenses
and so
do we already support a process with
reap to
support a number of students
um
as you said there's a three-month
waiting list we are working towards
talking to the right people um
to see if there's any way we can um
yeah speed up that process um
we're
gathering data through the high schools
to put forward a proposal and take it
further up the line and see if we can
get some money together to
yeah speed that process up
thank you mark
from from minus sorry just jumping in
there brahman um from my understanding
there's two uh significant aspects to
the
driver's license issue one is the the
training of the students and getting
them to a school level that they can get
their licence the other is giving the
testing done
and and testing
um in a lot of areas across new zealand
and also here is is one of the big
hold-ups so there does need to be some
central intervention happen uh in that
that respect i think
absolutely yes um and as bronwyn said
the waiting time is three months um to
get that license in place and then yeah
we need to do something about that
okay do we have any other questions here
from counselors
questions
you got your
hands off
my head thank you um
i believe the numbers are from learners
to full there's a hundred about 120
people waiting and part of the problem
um as i see is that
there are no zones and they the testing
people have people from
um dunedin young people from dunedin
coming down here for tests
so unless um
ncta had prepared to zone
and only gore and district people can
actually go to gore
or tiana people may be but
to have dunedin people coming down here
is just filling up
all of these um waiting lists so i think
that is that is part of the problem
so presumably they've got an even longer
waiting list in dunedin and they're
trying to
come down here and i know
it doesn't help a situation
do we have any further questions from
the
scanning the screens
nothing else there
okay uh just from the chair obviously
um i've been involved in the meetings
and various updates with you marked out
i know you're very proactive uh and we
are getting a really good community
profile around um what you're doing i
know businesses and employers have
discussed
um how it's worked well so you know that
that was the drive that's where it came
from and that's what um emir and the
various groups applied for the money
under
and we got it and we're using it and
it's um working so
uh you know job well done um driver's
licensing yeah that's been an ongoing
problem i know that year's
previous life that um it was always an
issue
trying to get kids through and get that
full license
um they'd go through the first part and
would sit and sit and never get it
tidied up um and they just ran the risk
so
i'm not sure what we pull out of the box
but it's definitely
one we need under the spotlight so
um so we have a report uh there um we
have someone
recommend that that's received
uh councillor davis and secondary
councillor grant
those in favor
carried
thanks mark uh keep up with the job
thank you sorry
i didn't give you a chance to wrap there
nothing you wanted to add at the end
there sorry i know i think the program's
going really well and um
we did a lot of pre-work before one july
around comms and tidying up bits and
pieces and mark started pushing out some
of those new messages so we i think it's
still running pretty good
can i just say uh mr chair that um as
jeff was saying earlier um this wouldn't
be happening without and support and um
and drive and um yeah it's her that's
making this happen and uh
go so successfully so thank you
thanks matt it's a team effort
here you go
okay
thanks mark and
well with that we'll be heading over to
and now for uh agenda item five the
event strategy
um
report that we have here
um obviously a number of councils will
be involved in the workshop and recall
that um and obviously we've got uh some
information here and some
recommendations so i'll hand it to you
as strategy manager um who's the
strategy manager
and also um whether you're going to be
assisted by a comms manager i'm not sure
who's taking the four
okay
i'm just um hopefully i've just shared a
powerpoint slide can you tell me that
you can see it
perfect okay so i'm just going to run
through some key points around the
strategy i think all of you have been
aware that
i've been working with sonia and it was
michelle that did a fair chunk of the
work as well
for this project now let's make sure i
can get this to work
so the background to the strategy
document it covers the period of
2021 through to 24. so effectively three
years which is aligning it to the
council's 10-year plan and it was
developed in conjunction with rebecca
mcrae um who has a consultancy business
and we were grateful for replicas
assistance in this process
it's really evident to me that gore
district
actually has a really good reputation in
the arts and the events sector and i
often hear sonia use the words that we
are the capital of events for southland
and our rationale behind that is we hold
two of the premier events within the
district tussock country
and uh the southern field days
so council spent a lot of time this last
i guess year 18 months consolidating its
approach and its ability to deliver high
quality events to the community
the strategy aligns really closely to
the southern defense strategy and you'll
remember that document came from great
south and to council for its feedback
and it's really important in our
relationship with great south that we
have our ducks in a row so they they can
really deliver well for the region and
part of the development of the strategy
that that is part of the purpose
so the strategy for school district
covers uh premium events and then it
actually covers the events we
own and run and that's a big focus of it
and then talks a little bit about the
special interest in regional events
so you're all very aware that we have
this wonderful positioning of rural city
living which is about encapsulating the
luxuries of city life but alongside our
rural city living
and so their rural lifestyle
i guess what was really what really came
through with the strategy and michelle
often talked about
our ability to run high quality city
class events but
in a rural environment so that it aligns
well with their positioning and i think
we're achieving that pretty well
the council's roles these are the six
roles that council actually has within
the event space so we're a funder so we
provide funding for other non-profit
organizations that are running events
for our district we're actually an event
organizer and that's just this role that
we're a communicator and a promoter of
events that are happening within the
district through our visitor centre and
tourism work
and we're also a host provider utilizing
facilities that we manage and we're
responsible for we have a regulatory
role and we're also in the role of
providing advice so council
uh as a major player in the event space
i think it's i think it's probably
become a lot more evident in
probably since christchurch earthquake
covered the actual important importance
of these community
events and the role that events play for
the community because it's often the
first thing that
councils and other regions try to
actually mobilize to return social and
economic return and if people are doing
well and they feel good everything else
tends to go a lot better so they're very
much about bringing people together
about showcasing what's unique for our
community
and raising that sense of community
spirit and pride and and we want to
celebrate our identity and we want to
assist with our community's well-being
so those are the sort of aspects that
the strategy is talking about and doing
for our community
so when we think about what what is the
vision um there was three
significant areas that the strategy
focuses on that with
that focus it will enable council to
continue to deliver high quality events
and those three areas are event
coordination development and investment
uh the event promotion and networking
and our infrastructure and service
so just to touch base a little bit on
these areas so event coordination and
development investment this is about
resourcing and you'll remember when we
workshopped
the strategy as part of its development
we we have a full-time person but the
strategy really highlighted that
actually there was a need to increase
the staffing by 0.5
or another option was to rationalize
some of the events delivered and we had
robust discussion about that and council
has taken the decision to actually make
the community awards every second year
as part of that bigger picture of how we
go forward
we have a grants policy currently at
council and the work that ruby could do
she actually reviewed uh what was best
practiced in with not just with the
event sector but with local government
and it is a contestable fund and often
uh
the rationale around this is it actually
assists event organizers as well with
their planning
because because they have to think in
advance and it also gives the council an
opportunity to align the funding that
they give to other events alongside
their plans and strategies so that tends
to be in the approach that a lot of
local authorities are taking now and it
seems to be working well and that is one
of the recommendations within the
strategy is to update the grants policy
sponsorship is a really big component
you will have seen that through the
strategy document where we've given you
the breakdown we believe that there is
opportunity
to grow our sponsorship but to grow
sponsorship you have to have staff
resource to build those relationships to
develop up the sponsorship packages so
this is a significant part
of maintaining and growing events
but sponsorship is also a really
important part of a businesses
advertising budget and to build their
brand awareness so we have to make sure
that we can do that well
we also the another area that we need to
spend a little bit more time in is the
measurement of events and the value and
impact and we've heard today with tusk
country i think it was 1.7 million
return and they did quite an extensive
piece of work in getting the economic
and social return
the intention
in developing this up is to work with
great south uh because they have a
regional piece of work
to develop the methodology so it's not
about our staff actually developing
those it's about working in partnership
to get some good outcomes so that we can
actually come back to you and tell you
what the value of your investment and
events and gore is
also today
in this event sector you have
environmental measuring is becoming a
lot more predominant and it is expected
and sponsors expect it as well because
they they are more choosy about what
events they want to be aligned to
and it's important that we're clear
about our values and how they align to
the values of the sponsors
so in the events
promotion and networking area the things
that we identified as actually at the
time of the development strategy we
weren't so well connected with the
national industry body and i know sonia
has done a work in that space as we've
been developing the strategy and we have
some good connections there
um we've got good connections with great
south that are working really well
and we want to do
better in connecting with our other
event providers within google district
and across the region because there's a
lot of learning opportunities but also
sharing resources there
and also it's important from an
advisory's perspective to our local
community events
on the work plans here at council there
is actually the development of a
marketing strategy for the district and
events are very much part of that and of
course the event calendar which already
exists with gorenze.com
this is often challenging though because
it's about getting the information
out of people so we want to try and do
better at actually keeping that
up-to-date in live but i think we do
pretty well and we can only really work
with what we've given as far as
information
and then the infrastructure and service
component is about procurement so one of
the challenges of being part of a small
district is we can't always procure
everything that we need within the
district so the strategies identified
that it would be helpful to
review the procurement policy of council
and
have it have some things in there that
make it easier to acquire
for events and also i don't identify who
are those preferred suppliers that
services this sector
the connectivity to events this is
always going to be a bit of a challenge
and it's probably throwing up even more
so since covert because we've lost a few
providers in the southern region and
when i talk southern region i'm thinking
um a little bit otago queenstown
southland because dunedin airport
queenstown airport and invercargill
they're all a gateway and we absolutely
saw that tucson country some people flew
into the cargo others flew into
queenstown so then how do they actually
get gore we have less
rental providers now since covert and
southland so that's another
you know challenge the other type of
challenge for our big events is people
getting around gore because we don't
necessarily have good public transport
and those are things like for tussock
country they've got a great system going
um to get their participants and
consumers of events the individual
events around our community so we just
need to work together to come up with
some of those solutions we still get
feedback in the catering space about
what is on offer in gore but probably
the bigger thing is that actually it's
having businesses open when people want
the food um services options and then it
has come up about aging facilities
within google district and the potential
that we might need a partnership
approach that's actually required there
um
so and the recommendations i have in the
report
uh um basically the approval of the
strategy so that it you know and that we
can implement it
that funding for
the 0.5 is at 27 440 as stated in the
strategy be put in the annual plan for
2022 to 2023
and that our grants policy is reviewed
and our procurement policy is reviewed
to provide greater clarity and ease for
purchase of services associated to
events
i'm happy to answer any questions and
i'm sure
um sonia will be as well
okay thanks and sonia is there anything
you want to add at the bottom of that or
just open it to questions so not too
many
uh thank you mr chairman um just want to
endorse a lot of ann's comments there
and the fact that the council's done an
incredibly good job
up till now um with the events that it
runs and the resources that it's put
into them and this uh strategy will just
provide us a very robust platform to
actually spring build us into
you know even more stronger events and
and strengthen what we already have
thanks sonia okay uh open it up to
councillors uh councillor ray brauman
um thank you mr chairman
i'd just like to thank anne for that
report it's very thorough
and just covers everything and i just
wonder if one of the things that you
have highlighted here was the about the
food and catering um
do you actually see
do have an idea or a way forward so that
in future you know
our cafes and restaurants will stay open
a wee bit longer just across that
particular weekend for tussock country
or
when we've got a lot of people in town
do you have any idea of how we go about
that i mean we want to include them
do we need a i'm not going to answer the
question for you but um
is it a matter of them actually seeing
the benefits
that these um festivals and things bring
to the town
um
and do they want to be part of it and if
they're not going to be part of it
what's what's the next step do we have
to look at bringing in outside
i don't know like coffee carts and
things like that
um i think that there's a few things in
this mix this needs to be more
conversation uh there needs to be a bit
of education potentially we've got to be
realistic that businesses will not open
if it's not financially viable for them
to do that
but there's some other issues probably
that fit into the education space is
actually about choice now that we do
have quite a lot of choice actually in
uh within the district but
there's a lot of ethnicities traveling
for these events as well and so the
expectation around what they what is
available
i think one of the things that we will
look to do is partner with great south
and actually like coin is just doing
some work in
um the food sector at the moment so we
just need to look at what else is out
there what's happening on the national
scene with events and see what we can
bring to gore and have those
conversations with the individual
providers
and it will be different from event to
events like tussock country different
different definitely needs um some of
those
you know providers to be open late
because we've got a party thing sort of
developing where people are out later
that you know going to shows and then
they want to go and have a drink or they
want to go and purchase not just the
middle of the road food
so there's lots of challenges in that
space it's not going to be an easy fix
no i appreciate that and i think that
was one of the things that one of the
very few negative things that came out
of that particular process was the lack
of ability to go somewhere and have a
late meal or something because they're
closing their restaurants early which
you know as you say financial
um
things come into that as well so but
thank you it's a good report and we look
forward to just making it better
uh
counselor thanks roman councillor dixon
oh thank you mr chair
um it's a great report and and i think
you raise a lot of very good points
what i would like to see is that the
funding for the um support person go to
a full council meeting
and
perhaps at the community grants policy
be reviewed in the procurement policy as
well
i think we can perhaps recommend it but
i would i think it needs to be actually
mandated by full council
it just didn't reply there again
we do recommend this through
um these minutes are then brought to
council where they're ratified so
um and the recommendation is there for
the grants to be reviewed so it does go
to full council um we can't actually
give it the final sign off so
uh we will be following that procedure
thank you
any other questions
tracy just do you just we're talking to
myself here putting my phone on
um just to to add there yes
i endorse what you're saying um and it
does need to go through council
if we if we add that funding into the
annual plan then also the community can
have their say if they want to as well
thanks tracy
any other questions hands up i'll just
check the other screens
no so
uh there's no further commentary there
obviously just um from chair that
probably the uh the term there in regard
to the food trade
and gore at certain times and certain
weekends of events i noticed that um
uh in the initial agenda item there was
mention of cheese rolls
every five metre
stalls up the main street there's
obviously some young entrepreneurial
person out in their community that's
probably cash in if some of our cafes
and restauranteurs
are not keen with your ass i dare say
there's probably
a market out there um but it's
interesting that that's come up across a
couple of their uh
items there and the other thing is that
obviously that cross pollination across
the area with um
various events is going to be the way
forward for us which is highlighted
through that report so we councils we
have a recommendation before us there
if i could have
someone
to recommend that uh
counselor read
and seconded
i'm happy to second that richard
thank you uh worship
so we have a report that's been tabled
uh all those in favor
aye
aye against
okay that's carried
thank you councils um so that brings us
to the end of the
um
agenda there uh no further items um
thank you to our community strategy
manager for um putting that together
if there's no further information or
discussion there um
no hands
technology has actually uh served us
well today we've managed to get through
those
presentations so well done um